forty divided divided by six holy [ __ ]
I'm dumb what are the four layers of the
earth this is great I really don't know
I'm gonna say crust is the outermost one
core is the innermost one and then
there's outer core land water and
surface air and the Sun bedrock rocks
crust mantle core when was Abraham
Lincoln president of the United States
definitely 1860s I don't know when he
was elected or how many like terms he
served or even when he was assassinated
sorry Abe rest in peace homie I'm gonna
go 1864 to 1868 1868 1860 to 1865 1861
was he elected president in 1860 and
inaugurated in 1861 right this sentence
is just a great quiz in cursive in
cursive I'm already struggling on
capital T how the hell do you write a
team wait no I remember how to do this
oh [ __ ] I messed up okay let me start
over
we'll just I don't remember how to do
and I that's not right this
capital i capital I so I'm like shaking
right now like I don't remember anything
about Curt sip I don't know how to do
capital letters no capital J
boy I remember J's looks kind of weird
find the smartest man in the world and
ask him to do a cursive Q he won't be
able to do it he or she won't be able to
do it Q's are weird Otto curve it back
down into okay and then the Z's like
some weird thing like that I don't know
forget it I'm over it already okay
[Music]
if I degrade myself on this I would give
myself a see-saw 45 divided by 6 I will
not be doing long division cuz I don't
remember how to do that so that would be
ok well 6 times 5 is 35 hold on wait ok
okay well five times nine forty five
okay what the hell how do you do
division so 6 times 6 is 36 6 goes into
45 okay
6 42 by 6 times 6 is 36 so you add
another 6 on to that
37 38 39 40 41 42 43 [ __ ] 6 times 7 is
42 funny remember why I was okay wait
okay so 36 point eight point two seven
point two I'm gonna say seven point
three is it seven point five sorry seven
point five seven point five seven and a
half boom
I feel like people in general or dumb I
think I'm like floating in between like
guys it's alright and well that guy's
really stupid I think I'm like a medium
ground I literally don't remember how to
do anything apparently third graders
they're our future cursive is a big
crock of [ __ ] you knock on the none
of this [ __ ] to be successful in life to
be honest so just do it because you have
to and then when you get older just turn
up like live your life
I remember in third grade there was a
rumor that teachers threw it out the
window
[Music]
you